vous citiez Laurent Wauquiez il s'est
très peu exprimé sur cette réforme
est-ce qu'il doit le faire plus
fortement justement pour donner un cap
c'est je comprends rien du tout moi
donc il devrait parler pour moi
personnellement je me suis exprimé oui
très clairement comment vous l'expliquez
je suis pas psychanalyste
psychanalyse pour vous salue la
politique ce silence c'est une matière
très noble la psychanalyse c'est une
matière majeure c'est ce qui permet de
comprendre l'esprit humain sa complexité
c'est une matière passionnante et qui en
politique comme ailleurs est extrêmement
utile l'avantage c'est quand on a un peu
d'expérience on progresse dans cette
matière là aussi Aurélien Pradier
puisque il s'agit d'une rencontre ce
matin Laurent Berger le secrétaire
général de la CFDT avec une conférence
de presse à la sortie sans problème pour
vous
c'est un choix qui vient confirmer sa
volonté de de peut être en difficulté sa
famille politique oui ça c'est
sûreté alors il a des mytes son poste de
numéro 2 mais est-ce qu'il doit aller
plus loin et sur des républicains en
réalité il y a le moment où quand on
quand on a ce type de comportement
systématiquement hostile
on perd en crédibilité quand même voilà
je pense que c'est pas vis-à-vis d'un
parti c'est vis-à-vis d'abord de
soi-même et puis c'est vis-à-vis des
gens tout court qui regardent tout ça
même des gens qui sont au style ne
peuvent pas se reconnaître dans ce type
de démarche c'est pas estimable parce
qu'on voit bien que c'est un calcul et
donc je pense que c'est pas l'idée que
je me fais de l'engagement politique on
peut être contre on peut être rebelle
on a tous été d'ailleurs Pradier mais
vous l'avez été aussi oui bien sûr mais
en réalité c'est pas le fait d'être
rebelle ou d'être hostile ou d'être en
différence c'est le fait de choisir des
combats dont on s'est pertinemment qui
sont en contradiction totale avec notre
philosophie politique oui il m'est
arrivé
mais c'est faux en fait au nom de quoi
est-il incarnation de la Droite
populaire
en étant contre une réforme des
retraites qui va protéger non seulement
les plus modestes mais les générations
suivantes mais où a-t-il entendu ça
depuis quand être
issu d'un milieu modeste comme c'est le
cas de millions de Français interdit à
ces millions de Français de se
préoccuper de l'avenir de leurs enfants
enfin c'est quand même dingue ça c'est
ça qui ne va pas et qui n'est pas
logique donc en réalité le problème
n'est pas d'être en hostilité j'ai été
souvent en hostilité avec Sarkozy mais
je l'ai été sur des sujets dont je
conseille qu'à aucun moment je ne renier
mes convictions bien au contraire quand
j'ai dans d'autres temps imposer la loi
d'interdiction de la burqa dont je dis
ça parce qu'on est le jour des droits
des femmes et comme vous le savez
c'était une atteinte majeure au droit
des femmes j'avais contre mal hostilité
avéré et de Fillon et de Sarkozy bon et
j'ai considéré que avec mes amis députés
nous allions imp oser ça parce que
c'était nos convictions profondes il y
avait une logique à ça bon donc c'est
pas la même chose que d'être hostile à
la réforme des retraites que nous
préconisons à droite depuis toujours
sans l'avoir toujours fait d'ailleurs
parfaitement donc là on a une étape
supplémentaire y être style c'est
incompréhensible pour les Français